at the high
level uh technically how does bitcoin
work
is there interesting things you could
say like what are minors
what are nodes full nodes what are
blocks
what's proof of work is there uh a nice
way to wrap up
a clean explanation of the protocol oh
man
that's uh that could be a whole that
could be another five hours
is there interesting because i'd love to
talk to you about block size wars and
sort of the
the the politics the psychology the
principles around that but sort of
building up to that it'd be nice to talk
about how the thing works
that's fair i mean and the block size
wars are a really fascinating
discussion of how governance debates
intersect with technical features um
so i guess we can yeah so basically
at the highest possible level bitcoin is
a
globally shared uh it's really a
replicated ledger that
um any participant that wants to be an
equal peer on that ledger
they want to maintain that ledger and
they want to stay up to date with the
global state
of the ledger and really any monetary
system is just
a ledger with physical cash
we benefit from the physical
instantiation
of the money though the physics is the
ledger the physics
is a ledger right same with gold right
you can't just produce new units of gold
so we trust that gold atoms are hard to
create
um although not impossible right um you
could uh fire a bunch of protons and
whatever
is the adjacent metal uh and create gold
atoms would be expensive
uh and the same with dollars you know we
trust that it's hard to counterfeit a
dollar
so we trust the physical analog world to
help maintain the state of that ledger
with digital money like you know the
money in your bank account
your checking account we basically trust
our institutions or banking institutions
to keep a faithful record
and then ultimately we trust the central
bank to administer that system
so there's kind of a handful of nodes in
bitcoin we trust that the economic
incentives of the system
are carefully poised basically so
we trust that the free market mining
competition
will lead to the miners assembling
transactions into blocks in a faithful
and correct way
and that we are going to converge on a
global state of the ledger continuously
which updates every 10 minutes or so
with some variants
and then the miners aren't the sole
entities that control the system
to really participate if you're a
merchant and you're accepting bitcoin
you really want to run your own full
node and check the whole history of
transactions
sort of something like i want to say
five to 600 million transactions that
have ever occurred on bitcoin
so full node contains all the
transactions ever transacted on the
the bitcoin blockchain and that's
i saw it's like 200 gigs or something
like that it's like 350 something like
that
it's doable on a regular consumer laptop
and that is going to be
really key later on in the discussion
sure
but so you know that's really the
ultimate trust models first of all we
trust that the miners that assemble
transactions into blocks and
they are the archivists you know they
inscribe those transactions onto the
ledger
and they have an economic incentive to
sort of behave correctly because they're
getting paid and no units of bitcoin
that's part of it but then really you
are also
you're not fully trusting them you're
actually if you want to run a node you
replay
every single transaction in the history
of bitcoin from the beginning
to the current day and you arrive at the
present state that way
so you don't really have to trust too
many people or entities
you can validate the correctness of that
all the rules have been followed
that all the bitcoins that were created
were done so in the valid
way that the inflation rate was adhered
to
and that there's no covert inflation you
know that
if you're spending 50 units of bitcoin
uh you had that bitcoin to spend
in the first place uh so it's sort of
delicately poised between node operators
who who you know engage in this validity
checking
kind of anti-counterfeiting checking and
then also the miners which are
an industrial entity and they basically
produce block space
and uh assemble transactions in the box
and everybody so the miners are
incentivized
to not mess with the system because
they're getting value from the system
so if they mess with it it's going to
decrease the value of their physical
work investment yeah so they have to
incur a real physical cost
to produce a block right so right now
you get uh 6.25 bitcoins in a block at a
minimum and then maybe some fees
as well how hard is it to produce a
block now
well challenging i mean you need uh
so 6.25 bitcoins and a bitcoin's worth
55
000 or so so it's probably gonna cost
you
about that amount to produce it because
it's a free market competition
and miners have very free thin margins
so it's like if i auction off a dollar
you would pay up to 99 cents to buy that
dollar for me
it's exactly what happens with miners
they're you know basically
uh competing for the right to obtain new
units of money so logically speaking
they would pay up to the value of that
money in order to earn it
and for people not familiar the process
of mining
is solving a difficult cryptographic
problem
that's a computational problem it's i
would say it's not like
people sometimes represent it as like a
really challenging puzzle like the
individual
puzzle is very simple like you can do
with pen and paper if you wanted
you know like shawn 256 it's just that
you're searching through the big
mathematical space to find the needle in
the haystack
you're just doing lots of iterations of
a simple puzzle
it's just brute force hence like the
stability of of the whole idea of the
proof of work
if it was a if you if there was a
shortcut it wouldn't be
it wouldn't work exactly so let's hope
nobody
solves sha-256 yeah there's a lot of
discussions in uh from the quantum
computing space but
everybody i i talked to all my
colleagues and
that work on quantum computers uh say
this were quite a way
quite a long way away from that being an
issue in
cryptography and then and certainly in
asian cryptocurrency
that should have been one of the sides
on these dice should have been quantum
quantum because
i don't think it is i forgot to put on
this edition
people should check out scott anderson
uh
there's a lot of people that are kind of
uh
selling quantum snake oil so you should
be very careful
i think it is a really exciting space
that might
change the world in the next decade or
100 couple hundred years uh especially
for simulating quantum mechanical
systems
but in quantum machine learning uh
people should check out tensorflow
quantum
it's a nice way to sort of educate
yourself about the space
and actually if you're pragmatically
minded to
you know through software engineering
explore how you simulate quantum
circuits
how you run machine learning on those
quantum circuits the the main
point that scott makes scott erinson
people should check out his blog too
is that like there's not yet
a single machine learning application
that doesn't do
almost as well on a classical computer
so it doesn't
like yes the dream is somehow
uh quantum computers will change the
nature of
artificial intelligence but there's yet
to be an actual
algorithm that or a problem set or a
data set
where that would be the case so
skepticism is good in this space
you